el objetivo finales de mayo el
presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció que
su país está en camino de tener
suficientes vacunas para todos los
adultos en apenas tres meses
con uno de mis primeros objetivos en el
cargo fue decir que se administrarían
100 millones de vacunas en mis primeros
100 días de mandato hemos llegado a la
mitad de ese objetivo en 37 días y
confío en que llegaremos hasta el final
para lograrlo badén informó que la
farmacéutica merck a ayudará a fabricar
la vacuna kobe 19 de una sola dosis de
su rival johnson johnson en una
asociación que según dijo es similar a
las que se dieron durante la segunda
guerra mundial
también invocamos la ley de producción
de defensa para equipar las
instalaciones de merck con los
estándares necesarios para fabricar con
seguridad la vacuna de johnson y johnson
las instalaciones de fabricación de
vacunas de johnson y johnson empezarán a
funcionar las 24 horas del día
por último bailén ordenó a los estados
que dieran prioridad a la vacunación de
los profesores para garantizar que los
niños puedan volver a la escuela de
forma rápida y segura señalando que
muchos padres estaban saliendo del
mercado laboral para ayudar a sus hijos
a aprender a distancia con 3 vacunas ya
disponibles la reapertura de las
escuelas es una necesidad dijo bayram
citando la creciente preocupación por la
salud mental de los niños y el riesgo de
que se amplíen las
variedades